à 14 15 ans la plupart des ados ne
savent pas vraiment ce qu'elles veulent
faire plus tard mais ils commencent de
plus en plus à y réfléchir et ses élèves
de troisième secondaire sont bien
curieux d'entendre daniel jacobs ça vous
demander qu'est ce que moi je pourrais
faire qu'est-ce que je peux amener comme
contribution dans l'ombre qui me motive
moi personnellement spécialisée en
développement durable l'entrepreneur
présentes sur le web les capsules vidéo
tournée un peu partout dans le monde et
il fait aussi de la consultation
d'entreprises
j'ai largement sous estimé que j'étais
pas nécessairement à l'aise devant une
caméra ou moins dans les premiers temps
il veut montrer à ces jeunes que se
lancer en affaires n'est pas toujours
facile le quai c'est un projet
accessible et réaliste
si vous avez une idée de projet en tête
que vous voulez réaliser
n'hésitez pas à en parler c'est comme ça
que vous seriez surpris de trouver des
gens partout qui vont venir vous aider
pour eux pour les réaliser et la
conférence a bel et bien donné confiance
à certains élèves
je suis beaucoup impliqué dans le ski du
tout fait que je devrais faire une
marque de vêtements impliqué là dedans
justement avec ce centre donne envie de
de faire des efforts oui parti de rien
qu'ils étaient capables d'avancer qui
faire beaucoup de trucs rick moi je dis
que je suis capable de partir de rien
augmentez vos changements
un fait devancer j'aimerais ça part sur
mon entreprise ça fait longtemps jeu
phare ça et ça m'a inspiré seront plus
accessibles parce que j'ai vu que tout
n'était pas de faire ça et mon style de
jeu
j'aimerais bien faire une compagnie
comme ça on veut susciter plein de
flamme pour qu'ils mentent seulement
peut-être qu'au coin de leur tête 2 3 1
bonjour oui je me rappelle de cette ut
est vraiment intéressant donc
l'entrepreneuriat fait partie de même
titre que les arts la culture de
domaines importants de la vie je pense
qu'elle est que les élèves pourraient à
l'explorer de plus en plus ici marie
claude morin radio canada montréal